this is binomial expansion be that the
messy one I wonder if you can find out
what is the term in that expansion that
is independent of X or another way of
saying that is what's the constant term
okay most of the terms are gonna have
some X's floating around there so
they'll be variable but there'll be one
term and not only one that's a constant
has no X's in it independent of X okay
so there's kind of like two three skills
in there they're all here all the things
you need so I want you to have a stab at
it and so I have begun is to say well
one of these terms will be because it's
on one of them will be independent but I
need to know which one is so known as
you work out which one it is I need to
know what each of the terms looks like
so that's why I go to the general term
okay so if I'm looking for the K term
what is the case ten a very started
writing it what else needs to get added
on to this thing the K term is going to
have some number of these in it and some
number of these in it right yep that's
okay
yeah so I'm including a zero term in my
scheme there will be a term zero the
zero term and that's because as we know
it's because of the way Pascal's
triangle is that you always have on the
in throat you have n plus 1 items right
so I just designate the first first item
as turn zero okay so maybe I should just
run take first ten I'll say turn zero
term okay yeah let it equal to end yeah
I will in a second I've learned a second
but I need to know what I'm gonna let
equal to that
I can't suit you me alright now let me
write this next line and maybe I'll try
and explain what's going along because I
don't know if anyone's following because
I'm a family okay you remember right I
can write this thing as like there's
going to be 13 times right
13 times I could write the first one as
this ^ 12 and then the next one will be
2 power of 11 intents after I've been
climbed down or totally I could write it
in Reverse or not I could write this
thing as the first term to power 12 and
then that's a pair 11 and 10 etc so the
difference is whether you start from
here or something there it's no big deal
okay so which one do you choose
now I'm just gonna start with the most
obvious one that's the first term so I'm
gonna say they'll be back thing to the
power of K and then there are we this
thing to the power of 12 - can you see
that do you see where I've got that from
that's this thing here except my a and
my B this and this does that make sense
now what I want to do is for some
particular value of K these X's and
these one on X squares will exactly
cancel out right that's what I want
okay so I need to tease out where the
powers of X are in there okay now I
think this is just probably the most
systematic way to do it to tease out the
pair of X's I'm gonna take well the
constant P so I already know any C K is
a constant thing it's a number of some
kind in here is a to the K and an X to
the K yes so the 2 to the K is the
constant part and then the X to the K is
the variable part I get the plot I want
to cancel out with you I'm just going to
keep on going there's a negative 1 to
the power of 12 minus K that'll be
constant if you have a 1 or negative 1
and then lastly there this guy would
help me out a little bit I'm gonna write
that in negative index notation okay ^
12 - case right now I'm almost there I
just need to get things in the
Whitewater
so you've got one two three terms that
are constant and so those terms that
really mattered to me right now on this
one and this one okay I should combine
their powers together because I want the
power to be
zero that would mean there's no excess
there right so let's have a look I'll
just write down all of this constant
fluff first now have a look at this guy
what's this gonna be this is going to be
2k minus 24 2 K minus 24 and then
there's a K there so if I multiply this
together I'm gonna get 3 K minus 24 yeah
did it do my indices right that is the
general term okay but what I want is to
set this thing to be it's the 0 right so
you can see it's a pretty
straightforward number crunching here
and that's what I've done does that make
sense and you should think about it oh
of course it must be right because you
see how you've got more X's here and
unless X is there so I've got to get
further into my series of terms in order
for these guys to cancel with it okay
so I've done that but what do I do with
this now that actually answer the
question yeah so the question was what's
the greatest coefficient so remember how
I sifted out all of this constant fluff
because I was like this is the bit I'm
interested in but now this is the bit of
interesting right I know this is going
to be equal to what so I'm just going to
say here's the actual term right so
therefore and I really should have
written that as a 12 guys whatever 12
choose 8 years times 2 to the 8th
negative 1 to 4 looks like my Negi is
and cancel to the v8 is 256 what's the
other bit someone giving them up you'll
be being wait really
that's it oh the whole number it's a 495
times 256 bit there we go
here is normal of course it is cuz talk
to use a to be number and so as to you